we haven't been to the jungle with
Tarzan and with Jane for such a long
time at the technology to bring animals
alive in a really compelling way to move
the camera through the jungle in a
really dynamic and exciting way all of
those things are enhanced and theatrical
eyes in an immersive way with imax and
in a way that allows the audience to be
immersed in that world you are toys a
movie like Tarzan lends itself to the
imax experience because of the
landscapes the immersive world of the
jungle ah the action and spectacle of
being in africa for an action epic I
wanted people to have a really
entertaining time in the cinema I wanted
it to take people to another place but
also to be moved I wanted to give them a
complete experience he's Tarzan you're
Jane he'll come for you for me as a
filmmaker I think the great thing about
imax as it gives you an arena experience
which is larger than life
they make the movie better a normal man
can do the impossible to save the woman
he loves my husband is no normal man